I don't understand.
Every time I go
through my hell loop,
I keep making
the same mistakes.
Well, that's because you're
avoiding your guilt, Reese.
You need to confront it.
You all do.
I don't know.
I'm telling you,
no matter how hard I try,
it feels like I'm destined
to make the wrong choice.
Ah, the old fate
versus free will debate.
My favourite.
But you see,
fate is just a result
of the choices
that you make.
Do you really think
it's possible to change?
Of course.
I mean, look at me.
For millennia,
I was down here,
stuck in my own
hell loop of sorts,
thinking I deserve
to be in charge
of people's punishment.
And then even when I left,
I found myself
in a cycle of selfishness
and violence,
debauchery, sex.
Yeah, I mean, clearly,
it wasn't all bad,
but the point is that,
with the right guidance
and the right help,
I was able to change,
to grow,
to find true
meaning in life.
I wish I could just…
take it all back,
everything
that I did on Earth.
I hear you.
I felt that way, too.
I wished I could do
everything differently,
but then I wouldn't
be the devil I am right now
sitting across from you
right here, would I?
I don't know.
Maybe I'm just a lost cause.
Nonsense, Reese.
And certainly
not on my watch.
Because if the devil
can be redeemed
then anyone can.
And if you can't,
I can just shoot you
in the face,
put you out
of your misery, no?
No, Vincent, nobody will be
shooting anyone in the face.
Clearly, you're going
to need a little more time.
Ah!
That'll be the doughnuts.
And the pastries
for you, Vincent.
Ah, c'est bon.
Hello, Detective.
I thought
you could use a partner.